uh let's go next to nick from ohio nick
from ohio what's going on
david can you hear me i can hear you
loud and clear my friend
it's such a pleasure to speak to you i'm
such a big fan of beta male and plasma
and all your other work plasma's huge
right now
hey so i've been pretty upset recently
with um
how democrats pelosi schumer how they're
dealing with um
amy coney barrett i i heard nancy talk
on a show maybe you heard this clip she
said she was asked by i forget who was
cnn msnbc something she was saying
we have arrows in our quiver to stop acb
from going through
yeah to stop this you know unjust
justice
from happening i i i watched closely
after that to see
you know we have heard you talk about it
on your show people talk about our other
shows like
impeaching bar and teaching trump again
holding quorums and forums
anything anything to take precedent over
putting in amy coney barrett so i'm
wondering what how
as as a young person in this coming into
this new election
how am i supposed to have a trust in
these democratic leaders to
to to hold true to their word to
actually take action when it counts i i
just
i can't be the only one feeling just
incredibly disheartened
disheartened and disappointed well
that's that's exactly this is this is a
great
question basically this is why we
shouldn't deify
any politician we shouldn't believe any
politician is going to do the things
they say they're going to do
and there are people who will
strategically apply that oh
bernie supporters say biden won't really
do the stuff he says or
republicans say well uh trump
the things that he says he's going to do
that are bad he's not really
or whatever this is the whole point we
need to just think
about our vote as a tool to try to get
something from our elected officials and
to have a plan to hold them accountable
democrats blustered about we might be
able to block it this way or that
now in their defense most democrats said
i don't think we have the votes to stop
it that was that was the reality and
that that was true
uh but you're absolutely right that
everybody wants to pretend to be all
powerful
and in the end it's a you know
repetition of the status quo
so we can't change everything overnight
but all we can do is who can we vote for
that will accomplish something that
moves things in the way we want to see
and then we make another decision and as
barack obama said and then you vote
again
and then you vote again but you're
completely right the deification of
anybody
as completely trustworthy as a
politician whether it's trump or biden
or
tulsi or yang or whoever
you know that's that no that's not the
way we should be approaching approaching
the political world
and you you seem to have figured that
out astutely so
great well i have one other quick thing
to add to that i saw that there was a
rule that the house
the democratic house or something
there's some kind of law where two of
the members had to be present for the
senate
uh process to even go through yeah and
of course of course mitch just waived
that because the democrats could have
just chose to not
uh you know be complicit at all right so
so you know when those when that rule of
law starts getting
i just hope that that we can find a way
to hold these people accountable and
and you know there's the subreddit keep
track there's all these different ways
that we can keep track of all the the
the minutiae that the the small ways in
which
uh our democracy is being dismantled so
so yeah well thank you david i really
appreciate you taking the call
and i'm a huge fan then thank you so
appreciate it
love the energy uh great talking to
folks
we will go to a break and we will take
calls again but it's going to be after
the election